okay ready what's up fool podcast work
so fool podcast
what's up fools ever do toys here yeah
man least their scores are and you got a
call we did a call
what's a full pot guide what's up fool
how's it going who am I talking to let
everybody know we're going live well
live on YouTube on slash awesome ATC
yeah awesome yeah what's up sweep a
what's up food this is Spencer Reilly
with Park I'd sup Spencer what's up
Spencer for hire good man ever tell you
heard that only for the old thanks for
thanks for having us on oh yeah my super
super excited man about the meeting
greet coming up this Friday this Friday
are you sorry about
I don't know a really awesome good
turnout you know you got bring some
stoners around you and I'm sure they'll
have a good time man and this is Denver
at peak dispensary this Friday 4 to 6
p.m.
yeah that's right and don't don't forget
if you mentioned Felipe you get a half
gram joint for a penny man yeah man how
many turns of that about her daughter oh
geez I'll be rolling with a couple penny
rolls in there you start your own
dispensary huh so everybody shout out to
Denver Colorado or anybody in the area
Aurora or Colorado Springs bro they
might show up man we drive people drive
from Boulder and Colorado Springs
yeah like when I was in Boulder people
joke about Denver over there so you know
that's right far if you live in Denver
man how about Aspen it's not yeah come
on anybody around the never area 46 and
come come each boy and how long have you
uh how long a spot guide been around
when did you guys start
Sopot Park I'd started in 2013 we kind
of started the site to fill a void our
art studio
and I saw the need for you know those
who are traveling to Denver to kind of
find out what they were supposed to do
people were coming here and buying
cannabis and they really didn't know
what to do after that you can't smoke it
on the street there wasn't anywhere to
take it so he was at least you know
letting people know the laws behind the
cannabis laws in Colorado keep people on
the right side of the law
and then at the same time we added some
lodging providers so some areas and
people who rented out say an air B&B to
cannabis users so that they you know
would steal not only safe but would have
a place to consume their cannabis so I'm
least kind of how the site got started
that's smart because I think that's the
problem in Vegas and all these places is
there's nowhere to smoke it there's
nothing you know you don't have any
guide to walking around like a criminal
gonna be nice and that alley that's what
I've seen you can see in you and it's
and it still happens obviously but I
mean even here in Colorado it's still
something that just recently with
initiative 300 it's you know social
consumption lounges are on the horizon
and one of them is actually open in one
of our clients and you can purchase
cannabis and and bring it there and
consume still no combustion allowed so
you can't take in a lighter you can't
smoke joints really more so vaporizing
and things of that nature but we hope to
see some changes you know in the future
because you're right like Vegas like
that's a huge Kent canna tourism spot
just because it's huge on tourism so you
know you have people going there that
are not only getting in trouble but they
just really have no idea what to do once
they purchase cannabis so we really hope
that that changes that can of tourism
just has so much you know potential
opportunity so right now there are there
are air B&B week the nikah smoke pot and
there allow it correct so we actually on
our site so a little bit of about you
know how pot guide runs and what we you
know do is uh where to buy where to stay
and what to do so are where to buy is
our dispensary directory so we direct
people to those dispensaries nearest to
them or in towns that they will be
visiting or the or account they live in
where to stay is through our 420
friendly lodging options and what to do
is our
or 20 and cannabis from the events and
activities so on that where to stay
option with the 420 friendly lodging we
actually have the most comprehensive
lodging directory for cannabis lodging
on online and there you know in many
different states that are on our site
say you know Colorado California
Massachusetts Oregon you can go on and
you can book rooms or you know a whole
apartment that will allow for first
smoking because the laws technically are
if it's in your own home so these you
know people have allowed that to happen
in their homes so yeah there's there's
really some places that you can
literally book online and just go blaze
up that is badass
right now jumpin up off a motel 420
friendly with only one floor no two
floors or less open up a hotel only has
balconies we're gonna make our extra
money on the way you can make money on
that matter
saw the grilled cheese it for $10 you
got a good idea there man you're gonna
have to call me when you when you get
that going off yeah all I need is a
balcony duck know that see and and
that's some of them as well some of them
do only allow smoking on a balcony year
say like you know on the property some
of them aren't smoking inside the house
but smoking of some sort on the property
is is ones that we list just because
again we're very you know education and
legal focus with our site so we don't
ever want to be steering people in the
wrong direction having them get trouble
so we want to be able to provide people
with a all-inclusive cannabis experience
so they can just really have the best
time wherever they are for sure
sometimes she goes oh really love some
stinky stink in his room like Stephen
and he not even um and he's not even
smoking it but the smell goes into the
hallway and everywhere and everybody
that doesn't smoke who the guest is
telling the everybody I think they're
smoking over there yeah
yeah Orlando or places like that they
can really give you a ticket like how
about is that against the law to roll it
up in some states for it like to roll it
up and like to just have it enroll in
yeah create an aroma so in Seattle yeah
la yeah there's there's still you know
I'll be like come on go go badly I mean
sometimes you know that's when you know
it's good you don't have to light it up
you just open the bag in the whole room
read hell yeah man now everybody's
weaved by the way only the best bath oil
you wanna go to the best I'll see you
guys March 21st
first oh sorry ahead of my time
that's the meet-and-greet and then New
Year's Eve know we're back the we'd
agreed and New Year's Eve you're coming
back to perform in Denver at Paramount
Theater retire bro so the first person
that has stinky ass has I'm ablaze I was
here it better be candy forever
handshake well yeah you know you know
when you come you know we got to because
we've we not only know where to where to
get it but yeah we've got the places to
to consume so you know you're in good
hands when you come here man so what's
gonna happen is that I'm people might
give me a lot of stuff that day and I'm
gonna be able to cook fly with a backhoe
so you know wafer savior for beer that
mean that there's a 31st put it in a
mason jar for you see what all the
secret stashes you're gonna be able to
puff on get out there
how about edibles bro what's the deal
with edibles edibles are that the edible
are losing their grade they're going
down
where's legal right the concentration
concentration the potency so so for yes
for edibles a lot of a lot of them
nowadays use use distillate
so it's a very responsive national oil
it may
it makes so you don't really get that we
D taste or that like really like
hangover feel from it usually yeah this
looks a lot cleaner of a high so a lot
of like the gummies and the edibles out
here not only a Colorado but in other
states as well started using that just
to again get that clean hi and to also
you know not have that that's lingering
flavor so you really can some of the
gummies out here and and we'll make sure
to steer you in the right direction on
that too and Peaks got you know a great
selection as well so I'm sure we'll
you'll be able to shop while we're there
but there's a there's just so many
options of awesome edibles out here and
I definitely gravitate towards the
gummies and those you know that tastes a
lot like the candies that I love so yeah
there's they're potent though you gotta
you definitely have to be careful and
that's why they do have different
regulations so you can buy you know a
higher milligram a higher more potent
item as a medical patient that you can
as a wreck patient just you know just
because they don't want people you know
eating too much and now falling asleep
for three days that's really the only
downside to too many edibles all right
was subbu
Thank You Spencer Wiley man for cutting
in and we'll see you guys man but on the
21st for shaking wait again we we
appreciate ya or do it yeah everybody
come out and don't forget man okay well
we will see other regulars and I show up
early when they opens what's up full
thank you very much for calling in yeah
thank you man yeah peace bees out of
this pot guy is the leading online guys
to find in dispensaries 420 for
enlarging cannabis events dispenser
deals and more they're bringing me out
to Denver this Friday to the meeting
Reed and Pete disparity from 4 to 6 p.m.
stop by take a photo safer say Philippe
and you're gonna have joy for a penny
half grab join for penny on the phone
all right Oh what's up upcoming shows
Denver Colorado you New Year's Eve at
the Paramount Theater Bridgeport
Connecticut January 13 affair at the
stress factory Turlock Turlock January
26 at the toilet Community Theatre by
sylia February 1st at the Fox Theatre
Coachella February 2nd at the spotlight
29 casino Raleigh North Carolina
February 22nd to 24th at the brand new
improv language it's like brand new it's
like they brought out another club and a
name of The Improv what's up boo
I'll sell now Wichita Kansas March 16 at
the Orpheum Theatre you better get those
tickets back because I only go there was
every 10 years
so maybe better get a fast all right
that's it yeah you got your little
Christmas spirit going on I got the
hospital released those chilly you know
be bad so we hit the hospital I love it
I go shopping put your headphones on
what's up boo worthy yes I'm here you
have right here Enrique Castillo bro
actor Chicago badass bro writer writer
and metal metal metal metal bro oh and
by the way didn't know that you were
part of them you wrote the last brown
hat you adopted it from them
the last angry hat to a play yeah cuz we
like to hang around with Willie Barcena
really know community Willie Barcena yes
he drank with him up he got you less
Russell more shot bro hey bro come on I
don't know he raved about the play when
he went to go see it he started like I
said sorry like two times which was
different
no he saw it because in a million
available part of it right when I was
involved I don't know when aminos it
never
but the way Willie Barcena talked about
it is like I'd know about it or like I
know like now all of it would have it
was written by Alfredo Ramos a fellow
robbers I know that for the you know
their billion news he's the generation
Xer okay Rommel Road he's you're hanging
around with some fool I know his name
but say I don't know the main dudes of
the movies who wrote it like another
sidekick bro like the guy that you know
like he's like thank you that guy that
hangs around with him because he's
trying to help up my haul you know he
was a shitty guy in a neighborhood but
he hangs around everybody has that guy
leave me some coffee Holmes that dude he
wrote and directed a film called
Road Dogg's that he worked with Jacob
vodka is something about a red couch hey
get out it was a red couch in a
neighborhood they all sat down on it I
think Danny little bus was in it too
yeah yeah or was that food stamps there
was another one he wrote and directed
yeah man I feel robbed was I met him at
a Willie Barcena house with a worst
enemy like yeah bro bro bro talking
Willie Barcena had a little pad bro
so that's before the house on up there
before the house the bachelor pad before
the big healthy ass now
he had a bachelor pad on top of the cool
restaurant above 7-eleven in Silver Lake
all tucked in there I took their nice
little place of 7-eleven across the
street for Sara Lee's marinelle easy
that was a good restaurant with a good
fish well as the first time I ever had I
bought pasta to go bro
all right ate pasta without pizza
as well as grow probably a pasta you
know the e a slice I haven't seen really
in a while he's still on the road nice
Road bad tired of most appearances of
The Tonight Show yeah that's right
bro 12 bro joke you little I have shows
in development - yeah God I was there
for like the last when he got to deal
with Fox that who came out of the Fox
office I was chilling outside talking to
this guy that was there pick sysm he
fixes those little cars the golf cars so
it was like a whole meet he recognized
me from watching comedy so he would
never talk to you I came out and Willie
Barcena came out do a roundhouse is bro
in the karate Creek Karate Kid crane he
killed he got a development deal they
canceled I really read it I saw the bro
[Laughter]
we are two deals we have one deal with
last time we're better Murrieta and
Bobby boatman we was they wrote the
pilot and they said there is there a
role for their roles for lots of people
but they said no to it but but then we
had another one another one based on our
lives and those that we've been shopping
around and we're still shopping around
we just we're done with the networks
because they all said no one and ABC
wanted it but it was too similar to what
another thing they got but the guy
robbed Danny Trejo not just because
you're Latinos but because a lot of the
content was similar so yeah that's sad
and I was too tall to be under Mayans
[Laughter]
but your little beads on that yeah there
we go
oh geez oh yeah and I have always tried
to do something together think we could
be mum done in some time
what's up with that oh hell yeah man so
we originally from you know actually you
know from oddly no I'm not I'm from
Imperial Valley or a migrant worker from
Imperials Raleigh right no Calexico
right ladies no order I'm an American
citizen past the wall by about a hundred
feet Wow bro I had a cousin passed away
I'm dressed
he's from Calexico Abbi hey Carly to go
back and forth right there
he knows who the real me club bro he was
half his daddy was white I found out a
year ago and his mom was my dad's cousin
not deem that to the max yeah my
grandson is a chili would eat oh yeah I
know man will do what are you bro you're
a [ __ ]
yeah we don't know where the original
people came from but Jewish do percent
Irish I know you do you do one of those
things like somebody my family did it
and you're like you're from oh yeah it's
not like you're a purebred or something
yeah who a mestizo everybody's 39% in
American their percent Greek Italian and
they're dumb there's a person every
letter said African and there's little
little ones you know like you know like
Slovaks last lovak finish Islander or
whatever
virgin Ivory Coast come on bet they can
so two putts murder but they can fight
they could take my blood all the way
back to like a slave area they say your
DNA matches people in that region who
are native today
yeah but do you think it's kind of
[ __ ] little trackers what data that
is my daughter dude I think my youngest
daughter what you think came out the
same thing like 39% Native American yeah
but what does what does that mean
exactly you had a lot less Native
American didn't you yeah it was yeah I
found out one of my kids actually not my
kid during Christmas you get him back
how'd you make it out to Los Angeles
roundabout way I went to college at
Berkeley in summer of 68 68 when all
about who you was going on down that
Louise my best there from a death-row
campesino eventually became a member of
his company after I left the company I
did music and San Jose then I wanted to
get back into performing arts so I moved
to LA June of 78 and in July I started
working in zoot suit with Lewis at the
Mark Taper Forum wow that's a roundabout
way from you and I grant worker to
Berkeley to how do you make it out to
Berkeley is Reece Martin school or was
it was through the EOP program
educational opportunity program for
underprivileged so they the I had
actually I had a mentor in high school a
teacher that took special attention to
particular students and she she gave a
test one time on Shakespeare which I did
well on and she said okay I'm gonna put
you in my prep class college prep I'm
gonna take you under my wing and then
I'm gonna make sure that you fill out
all the paperwork everything to go to
Berkeley and she did it got me over
there and then I flunked out my first
quarter and I acted my way back in
really when you're a farmworker kid with
no experience whatsoever you know you
you spend your summers working in the
fie
you don't know a lot about college
college courses and stuff so you
MacGyver away everything everything you
can say it sound like if I'm a Steve
ball it's like well but what you do but
what you do learn in the fields is
perseverance is mine oh you don't give
up because once you bend down better not
get up that's not her do you know you
think you can get back down you know it
feels like we're now when you learn that
Vegas wrong it's the other blowhole in
their high heels walking down what you
take off those shoes laughter walking at
Marlboro high heels though febrile I
like our line [ __ ] wooden windows
brother like don't let me rock this my
wife was always like that right there
just might use in the long legs and then
after a while like yeah you know I gotta
take these off so you know I always tell
you know bit of divest chic so uh
somebody said the capper McFarland
Farland that's the way that's my story
actually yeah that's the way I was I was
a track athlete in high school you were
yeah I was just three state champion so
you got that you still like a little
you're in shape I like what do a brother
he was picking up taozi when you're
diabetic you have to watch the Wade you
have to watch the nutrition you diabetic
early no I onset type - but I'm insulin
dependent cuz my pancreas doesn't make
insulin I'm waiting for the stem cell
best you get diabetes huh black people
get sickle cell now you got a lot of
people get why people go bald and just
depression Penny Marshall rest in peace
complications with the bathtub well you
know one of those kids brother I would
watch TV and try everything that
happened on TV bro I ever tell you I
swallow a little screw bro whatever I
choke to death outside threw him up my
dad's car
you know he threw that which was just
one of that school girl stuff I started
on alfalfa doing it and they're in a
Perry Marshall with Laverne Laverne and
Shirley she would put coke
Cola in milk Pepsi Pepsi in milk and the
one and I don't know how to do it but my
friend
I could never get milk and Pepsi
together like in my house we have milk
but we never have perhaps even ever an
opportunity man you know that Pepsi be
gone in an hour bro you make your own
soda right when you don't have any money
money you know you get a glass of water
right and then you put some some some
alka-seltzer in it and put sugar in it a
little Sally coke on my first beats it
was in college been on my life you know
you wonder like whether in Iraq we had
these ingredients grown up we got a
Calexico now and it seems a little like
you know rural you know it was probably
way more right way more there was there
was probably not even ten thousand
people around that time yeah most of the
little towns cuz yeah and Hebrews right
in between Calexico and El Centro intro
that my boss in New York who is
Dominican and he grew up in a real rural
area and in a very poor area and he's
they he said that they had no
refrigeration so to make the water cold
they would have like really strong mints
and or cough drops yeah cuz they they
sucked down cough drops even when they
didn't have a cold and like why you guys
have to eat all these cough drops yeah
they would call him mint we had a swamp
cooler that's the only cooling thing you
know we had in the house but if but if
you don't have that then what you do is
you go to the to where they have the ice
boxes you get a big piece of ice or a
big block of ice and you get up Dena and
put water in it and you put the ice in
it put it on the windowsill and then you
put a fan in front of it from the
outside
yeah yeah radios back
that's like down like Matthew
McConaughey and interstellar officially
gig bro walking with a little brother
carrying ice bingo ice cubes bro like it
over the route though you drag it that's
a mean man ass all right there yeah you
drag it on okay but that was back then
right if you had a refrigerator
you just have to box it me and you got a
paper I should put inside right cuz in
the old school cars - they have that
compartment when you hang on the window
and you put ice in there and it makes
your little air flow well you did
whatever you yeah I mean their
conditioning yeah you roll down the
window I knew because we were migrants
so we travelled through the valleys in
the summer there were like five of us
kids plus parents plus all the luggage
and everything and no air conditioning
so you're talking like 100 over 100
traveling through the valleys and then
you get there and you you know you you
have that kind of like essence about you
that aroma you know very nostalgic
reminds you of old homes so your family
will follow the crop yes like let s
celina strawberries in the winter
seasons particularly a little turntable
Mendota
Mendota yeah which is in the San Joaquin
Valley and it's the cantaloupe Kingdom
of the world
Wow but Botox I remember that you got to
go there man good stuff there so we
spent summers working a lot there you
can't elope in the sheds so bend down
and get him that no well we worked the
fields we did do that but mostly we we
did the the sheds so my father had his
own crew and he didn't that's the other
thing he didn't have any women on his
crews because he didn't want the women
working along the guys cuz the guys
would flirt with him right slow down the
work and everything and when you work
and in the conveyor belt in the packing
shed those cantaloupes weighed at least
5 pounds each six pound seven pounds the
big you know they come in different
sizes so when you're working at a fast
rate you got to pick up one cantaloupe
with each hand and he always felt that
women were gonna use two hands for one
kennel so he never let women working
ya know slowing down of the production
what's yeah yeah so be you're basically
beside the conveyor about your hands had
to like take on their own and be there
oh it's all conveyor belt pretty market
you get one that tails without even
thinking comes yeah well yeah you know
second nature you sort your sort them by
color by car that's knowing your eyes if
your mind knows that you're you have the
program to do that already
so usually your old machine yeah well in
our case my brother yeah my father
trained us when we were very little I
mean we were working in the fields with
him from the time we could walk you know
and we we worked holidays weekends and
summers so it wasn't like everybody else
you know the holiday you go hang out and
have fun with friends on the weekends
too we were working with my father we
were responsible for his truck to clean
it and put water and ice in the in the
can and then drive with him at 3 o'clock
in the morning to set it up for the guys
to cross the border and get on the truck
and everybody knew unless you were part
of his crew you didn't get on his truck
he is very strict about that so if we're
working my brother now we had to be
better than the even the grown-ups cuz
he didn't want anybody to say hey you're
treating your kids better and everybody
else so he would throw that on his head
as if we were too slow
rocks yeah that book every brother dad
man they have not told about the the
slaves who were picking cotton and when
they were put up what they were put the
seed in you know they were put up CDs in
one hand and then pick out the pick out
of the bad stuff out of the pick up pick
up the Torrens out of the cotton you
know real fast and then but you see at
the same time without crushing the flour
the flour has to be perfect and and then
when you picked out the car yet to pick
the cotton out and leave the flour there
and without you know you go home without
with a bunch of pies on your fingers but
there it's just like Deacon was talking
about his hand when the cantaloupes
but his father throwing rocks at him to
speed up
these people are getting whipped you
know of course the mutia whip the faster
you will go so that so you know you have
to cut like a [ __ ] machine bro
yeah like cart Georgia does so you
[ __ ] scared so you going faster huh
like Charlie Chaplin yeah times you
become wearing the Machine and cotton
gin yeah - there was to pick cotton bro
almost a hundred years before ya know it
all breaks down like you know which
slave owner had the resources and all
that stuff we can't afford all that so
yeah properties totally but you still
need oh you've been being to pick the
cotton off the fields rather than come
to 1953 to actually machine came in and
picked it up yeah but it was off - from
18 1867 bro Eli Whitney's cotton yeah
interchangeable parts and then of course
humans can't work at the rate that
machines can that's when drugs came in
yeah to keep the people going of course
those drugs in the fields - I don't know
I never had any like black coffee as a
kid you know you know the boxer gospel
Oh me know yeah Carlos was telling me
you from the valley yeah yeah he was
telling me when he was a kid when he was
a toddler
you know they were drinking still from
the bottle that his mom used to put
coffee in his baby bottle yeah mess over
like giving a little kid the key letter
tooth no never saw that no I heard about
it but I know but when you're sick they
used to put a lot of alcohol on you you
know you got a fever they paid really
yeah but get you drunk to remember that
next time
are you drunk no no no thick you smoke
Aquila for kids when they were teething
- yeah I remember that one man Humphries
[Laughter]
what how do you go from working in the
fields and traveling with your family
it's to like you know having that thing
that your heart you want to be an actor
a performer well we all like movies and
as kids you you like performing but I
never saw acting as a craft then when I
went to Berkeley and I saw Luis Miles's
of death row campesino do a show not
only were they performing but they were
performing characters that were like me
farmworkers spoke English in Spanish and
the families were very much reminiscent
of my families so we started a he had a
class at Berkeley that I took I didn't
know who he was at the time but when I
met him then we start we actually
started a theater company at the
University called echoes and soul no
yeah something like that anyway so we
did productions with him he directed a
piece and stuff and then he invited me
to become a go down to the first day at
Ronis you know their salon workshop in
San Juan Bautista where his company was
I went things went well he invited me to
be part of his company and then in 78
when he was going to do zoot suit that's
when I moved to LA so a friend of mine
well pepe said 'no yeah he had been in
the workshop production of zoot suit and
he was no longer gonna be in it because
we had both audition for a movie called
walk proud at the time it was gangs with
robby benson a job you would you gotta
walk through a straight line yeah anyway
so pepper got the role that we
auditioned for and he said hey but you
know they're doing a play and Luis
Valdez is doing a you know Louise why
don't you go and see if there's a roll
up and so I did auditioned and I got the
role of smiley
and then when the show moved to
Hollywood to the Aquarius Theatre I went
really well and then they were gonna do
the New York production Broadway and I
chose to stay here and I was doing the
lead if I went to New York I probably
would have gotten a supporting role yeah
so I decided to stay here and I think I
made the right decision cuz New York
didn't go well and then I stayed in the
show so I worked in that play for a year
and I did every single performance I
think I'm the only actor that ever did
every single performance of that show I
got an agent out of it I got my first
movie role out of it was probably wrong
it was a thing called borderline with
Charles Bronson and it was at Harris's
first time also yeah I played ed Harris
his sidekick got along well with Charlie
Bronson who at the time was you know
highest-paid actor in Hollywood
the comedian Tim Thomason yeah he used
to do a great Charles Bronson he would
put a beanie on right no but he pumped
he pumped and then he would start doing
journalism ed Harris broke ribs and
titers of it truly show the right the
right stuff he played John Glenn I
worked with him on Nixon also afterwards
you know Nixon the movie yes I he worked
on that too so we connected again I was
gonna do another film that he was in
called Walker a real life character that
went to Nicaragua because he was in that
it was an independent film so anyway
that's how I got to Hollywood and then
the rest was I got lucky I worked I was
here for a month and then I got my first
job that's awesome got an agent got
three I worked on the incredible
honk a couple of episodes the first one
would Lou Ferrigno and then from there
you know mr. McGee don't make me angry
we had to we had the guy that dresses up
like a hog in Hollywood Boulevard
initial he the crazy guy like the
monster know there are bill bixby
Hollywood Boulevard as the Hulk
it takes picture with people at hustles
everybody's icing her first name they
reek weed David McQueen the guy that
does hate to love that show man if noise
ed with him hitchhiking it's funny noise
you grow older if I wonder if things
about the hog leg he always bought a
pair of pants his eyes yeah but I never
big waist 34 and yeah when when he but
when they busted open
they always busted at the right places
right yeah the way stayed and part of
the legs to cover the rest of it just
genitalia to the same happened with a
little leaf that covered it up when he
was a monster didn't he lose his
genitalia cuz monsters like figurines
they didn't - you know David she's not
really a monster
like The Creature from the Black Lagoon
no Superman doesn't have any I think
they were credible Hawk was done when
when they busy they were bad it was
getting his ass kicked at this at this
bodybuilding tournament then he and he
gets all bad and he chases a dude on
stage there was clapping at the Hokie
thought ball for everybody else but he
agreed
everybody's happy in the hole goes
Ronnie clapboard early he was Posey
flexing you heard Mr Universe contest
whether without steroids no probably but
I'm sure they are
come on so we will use steroids you get
funnier imagine there was comedy
steroids come on should we do up there
Bob
break into microphone can you can you
get a comedy implant because I'd like
what hello
clones that that'll work and Lika killed
it are weeds I killed a lot of people
aren't weeds
Felipe could have play the Mexican Hoch
alright I remember I seen you know Mars
Attacks that was cool yeah yeah I had
even forgotten I was in there yeah my
daughter and I went to see at one time
and we were sitting there eating our
popcorn and all of a sudden she goes hey
something I mean stuff I never agreed to
be on like those we're at The Comedy
Store and then I was doing that show
with Tony Hayes cliff Keo Tony there's a
bunch of amateur like amateur comedian
but young comedian who was trying to
make a name for themselves you know
coming up in my case open my curse
so they perform and then like comedians
who've been around for a long time give
him critique up oh man you should quit
or you should change this show to that
joke but it's real funny cuz I guess
he's up there taking it you know but
this guy the African American comedian
ever heard of he's not funny funny first
are doing stand-up comedy he shows up
with a camera crew begging to go on so
he goes on and then they filmed him they
filled him on they feel him performing
and then steve-o was in the back the ADA
girls Tebow did the interview before the
world if you're a bunch of people you
know we don't know what the hell's going
on he puts that all in a movie it's a
I'm TV right now and it goes I keep
telling his head
I never agree to be on this I'm rather
leaving so well to the premier no red
carpet yeah but it was weird because he
was like they were promoting it yes you
are we shot at the car oh that was you
like that was for a movie like what
that's so weird
anybody ever seen the release by next
word was but no next what it was but you
bombed [ __ ] we do the worst community
of the show in history like if you would
like anybody bro oh he's a buddy I just
wanted to stop they can get away with it
by Konnor documenting it was Bowfinger
is emilio still doing standard show that
one time you did it alone yeah it's been
a while the man in the little boat Eva
was the thief Lula 30 called hey Charles
do you do you remember the the not a
racist °o° events that we used to do at
latc
downtown it was an annual event that we
did and was a comedy thing centered
around the Day of the Dead we used to
bring in all the Latino comedians George
was the first time George when he was
young kids would come by - yeah you know
right - yes yes yes yes well he was part
of a Chicano Secret Service back in the
day right Martinez by fire they did the
show and so did yeah it was 1993
your comedian yet you're just starting
thinking funny there when I first
started I was look at the alley
weakly to look for open mics and I will
see that CSS every Willie Barcena told
me that there was a Chicano secret
service right mm-hmm
and I was was Alphonse with that that I
don't remember I only remember Lalo
about Rafael Martinez the gal to the
photo from Italy and he knew a little -
oh you mean Rafa names not Martinez Rafa
and la right yeah so what was your road
to where you are now I well you asked me
where I started how I you know the road
to where I am now
oh I started I want to keep in a rehab
[ __ ] him at a rehab and I went to a
pizza by Ollie weakly you're in the
early 2020s and I saw open mic open mic
I don't know what to do so I why comedy
okay I love stuff accompanied by Rodney
Dangerfield oh I will my general when I
grew up
everything was that was cool capable
when I was a kid like VHS DVD CDs and
between was laserdisc
yeah my cousin hey I still have a player
and discs I have the three original Star
Wars wow those are badass he put all
them back there now how about the album
with Peter Franchot money well I have
Yellow Submarine - and I wonder the
movie that was a blue disc was such a
peppered Lonely Hearts Club and the
movie yes
see my cousin is West Side Story yeah
The Criterion Collection has a lot of
area enough that I was dumb
so you know if you want to borrow some
but it was a VHS I borrow for somebody
and I don't know they were break the
clip on the side of the beach and I get
cut it and then availabe a channel be
six hours now so you can record six
hours of stuff so they had seven hours
of comedy in it
Paul Rodriguez however now
Robin Williams other good HBO specials
you know just I've ever raised other
jokes but you also listen to the Bill
Cosby album also we also had seven hours
of porn
- the worst porn ever that was it just
then you just care kept trying and
trying for open mic but I was always
fighting around my friends but not like
though I let the class clown I used to
open up for him
I just saw his birch HBO so you need to
be over yeah my second special my wife
and I we produced it and we sold through
HBO you said take this there's nothing
out there we have George Lopez okay
miracle promote my way his his order
[Laughter]
what's up fool I get no respect
I get no respect already danger for it's
a beginning yes I love that no common
emailing we want a lot of company
growing up with to watch the Spanish
shows not polly was this cheeky yeah -
woo just Billy told Charlie Lord show me
and I'm from the contains lacerum other
Spanish was broke a team for us the
movie will play the carp couple leader
although you take a Buddha yeah and of
course Dean Todd but my dad would tell
me about the FO I'll go back to like
pre-teen time resources all the carp
arrows that's where what's an accomplice
yeah yeah so uh how do you go from all
that to blood your blood out Brock bound
by order by the way with the real game
with a bully that movie man I didn't
Kate when they were shooting that movie
I remember him because I just came on a
rehab and I wanted to avoid everybody
like I don't want to go back to the
cholos you know or my hobbies or
different brown people get away from
everybody
and I was dating somebody know somebody
from them from an na meeting she he
wasn't well he was he he he wanted to
drive always the project
you just punished enough right here drop
me off in the corner
you know walk in cuz every time anybody
will drop me off in front of my mom
house five people run out sell crack
they're all friends but they didn't know
but they don't see me all she is Batman
then they all run like roaches when you
open a little each other lights on but I
had everybody dropped me off you know
I'm walking and I see though I know I
see an actress in a movie I think she
played um she played the in chiapas mom
me Glow her she played a mom okay and
weird cause I throw the same age all
right Jenny Jenny Gaga and I know her
from up she did a mini series that was
badass called um the camera in a story
and and camera and I'm coming right now
my wife is in it but it's a Toro played
on caro quintero called your wars yeah
Kiki was my next-door neighbor he
proposed a babe Enrique Camarena oh he
really really yeah is my next-door
neighbor so he grew up with the you know
him yeah Wow
yeah his mom my mom were friends he had
two other brothers one of them was
killed in Vietnam just killed the drug
wars unfortunately only son that was
left was into drugs
oh yeah well they like did you guys know
that he was undercover I hadn't been I
hadn't heard about what he was doing for
years I just knew that he was working
for the government with a DEA but that
was about it and I didn't learn a lot
about how involved he was until
afterwards so that's why I found out
about blood and other other little blood
I'm walking right I see Jenny goggle and
you know me boy if I know you I shoot
out the last year I saw you want oh my
god you were that sure I saw man I would
hook that miniseries about the drug wars
you know they're redoing it yeah
and then I saw one of the homies from
the neighborhood named Caesar kill yoga
and I remembered I forgot shine a face
one time and then they stitched it up
and I guys hit whoosh I was saying I'm
sorry they're full he wasn't he was like
an external and blood and blood out and
he kept those housing project where they
were shot where Jenny Gong who lived
with me Chlo that's my hood man
that's where I grew up he currently so
yeah but that's that right there it's
called Pico Gardens but the other side
copy collie support there right there
that's my hood I had just came on a
rehab and I don't know ever show you the
movie off there's a goddamn would be
crazy shooting here so that [ __ ]
buying that neighborhood and so I see
him he go what he's doing man oh man
they should leave this movie bound by
honor he goes what are you doing it
because oh man I did all those had I did
all those tattoos for everybody here he
goes I did the henna tattoo instead
offering tattoos Wow something I got to
rehab so creator ology together over
here to be being gangbangers hooked on
drugs they [ __ ] working at movies I
quit nothing doing it huh
for real but he put other he put other
tattoos and so they shot him right there
yeah there was Mark Sanchez was one of
the makeup artist Kenny Kenny Diaz he
was the main guy film on T and then
there was that what's-his-name he was
just that there we had her because we
had the reunion the cast reunion well
right over at blackwell Duda yeah Taylor
Hackford was their director his wife
Helen Mirren was there to the Hackford
on yeah yeah he got an Oscar for a
married to Helen Mirren now he's married
to Helen Mirren yeah so she made it to
the reunion
Victor Rivers was there just let Danny
didn't Danny couldn't make it and Miko
was in Europe Jubilee Benjamin Benjamin
was in San Francisco I think he was
working
so he didn't make it but Jesse did Jesse
boreg oh yeah Osito Osito man
when we have David chop on the show we
asked him about a lot most of the big
questions that people people ask the
best are other fans because everybody
watches it at least five times a year I
know I watch it I fight every year let
it blow down what the director's cut all
of the even longer
he said that we always wonder why
they're so close to American me and
David said that the original book or
screenplay was huge and he said the
Energy's almost took the Latino side and
someone took the white side or JP
Morgan's I know my understanding was
that it originally was going to be a
trilogy Wow
like The Godfather oh so that it would
be badass so that it would have big it
would begin like it American me in the
40s and then it would go to the period
where the main gang was created and then
it would be the revenge of my character
getting killed
yeah and the daughter actually exacting
revenge that was going to be the third
one but it never happened because
whatever creative differences political
differences or financial things happen
so Universal got one story and Disney
got blood in blood out
Wow that would have been bad at huh
crazy man yeah there's a there's a lot
of calls for the another part but I've
I've met and I've spoken with Jimmy who
Jimmy Baca Santiago Baca the poet he he
played my celly got boy in the movie he
owns part of the rights to the story
because a lot of it is his life
but then of course Jesse then huh he
just he's just kind of a Mitchell Jesse
carrot to the people yeah basically yeah
yeah the artist goosey toe although
although he's a poet and an author and
we he was doing a reading of his work
down in San Marcos and we sat and talked
and basically we think we were trying to
figure out is there a possibility of
doing another one and Jesse what reco
has tried also Jimmy's idea was for us
to get a hotel room somewhere sit down
and try to hammer out a story but we've
yet to do that because it always takes
money you know all right man anybody out
there man who has blue the baller won
the lottery who won the lottery who's
making a lot of money deep pockets deep
pockets deep pockets we're talking we're
chucking of fifty five thousand dollars
up front right now to write the scrip
easily all right and it will make you a
partner will give you will make a
producer and will give you um five
points in the movie and also uh you'll
get you get to be a backstage anybody in
your family wants to be in a movie
we'll get him a walk on stage all right
and if you have a low rider all your car
special offers matter unofficial fifty
thousand dollars to produce the movie
this one man we're gonna go in front me
but I don't have to go out not gonna a
couple of houses man we're gonna need a
million dollars pretty much a million 1
million dollars just to learn lower
names to say hey man guess what man okay
we got [ __ ] uh we got merely van
right now man we got Wendy Barcena oh
[ __ ] stop it Danny was in it already
yeah
you have pochet yeah well you know I
told you I told Jim Ibaka and and Jesse
I said but my characters dead about oh
and all of a sudden it's like oh that's
right I said wait yeah but you know he
has a twin brother go back there bro you
come back Oh be one could all be as a
ghost turn it into a zombie movie for us
other words we were thinking you know
like we have no money either but we
talking about just make it make it a
night cuz we saw it's crazy it's crazy
and play up my birthday called um Point
Break live and what it was about hold
break life yeah it's about Point Break
movie Keanu Reeves people questions
Thank You zerah eaves you know and Gary
Busey but you know people questions now
Cavalry's a cute ability give some
calories bro I don't really know how to
do Keanu Reeves but I know they say he
does the same character but do-over that
movie with a child Travis oh yeah
[Music]
he was good as the older brother river's
edge well he was good movie it was also
perfect for some it's perfect for the
matrix yeah
yeah but the river's edge that was so
good because all those loser kids in a
movie could be losing real life well
that's funny that killed that guy killed
his bed his girlfriend and everybody was
new a body but nobody was nobody said to
call the cops
cuz they're all scared I remember you
were that movie right by which one of
these are the glitter glitter no river's
edge it wasn't oh yeah yeah represent
yeah yeah well it was shot in men some
teammate a California man Oh a mint oh
yeah so in that play these people
again a bunch of people together to play
other parts but they the the the funny
part is the Keanu Reeves part is given
to somebody in the audience yeah I
randomly choose and then a girl with
placards has all his lines so they get
it's funny cuz having somebody read them
but the rest of the people and it was
their surf read but it's interactive
like you get spray people they put
coconut butter on your body so you could
smile like you're surfing I didn't have
seen that scene where uh where Gary
Busey goes you know what it's gonna be
parts and --which doing that scene of
the play they saw me percent much my
everybody so you're thinking of doing
the safety of blood in blood out live
why not and have it like you know
whatever you know if having people play
your part your parts but we do have the
cash invite you in to play your part one
time but I choose any anybody who have
white or those white me grow the
audience we have the same thing pretty
much do the same thing and then but us
that the scene where we close shows up
it was simple kisi holder you know
tamales everybody gets a tamale like
there's a lot of wave making some in my
house right now
oh well better I'm sorry if I every time
the first time I ran into you were that
the terrible viewers that baseball game
with uh with the hot cheetos Laker game
yeah I was like a rookie there bro
latest in our bro have you had Richard
on no man yeah yeah
Yeah right they got put you to just give
us $2 for cheap times hey funny boy
every I watch a wrestling match in
downtown LA or ever go to those
wrestling like Lucha Libre you know you
should go there now so you know how many
people recognize you be like no way some
of the other people like anyway some of
the people the people they put up there
they recognize that but maybe but you
like to to us you like I caught the yeah
man so was it like calm you know like
we're not gonna support it we're like
Star Trek like you know there's there's
trackies for Star Trek there's crazy
people who like Star Trek the people who
like ready to who like Star Wars we
curse people who love blood in blood out
Letty's over the world and look for that
Muslim chicks oh yeah and then there's
uh there's people who love who love Big
Lebowski and every little tiny piece of
that movie people remember and every big
I think what's his name um Michael Pena
the actor he said he saw blood and blood
out if they want to be an actor when he
saw it the game for him in Chicago he
from Chicago right right right he played
such a Chavez your soul your role was
very very political changed right and on
the movie you got very political and you
will unite both sides yes he was a very
naked strong huh
yeah he leaned over very well-read he
read Dostoyevsky
Nietzsche Ichi that like the at a store
astok foreign culture so he's very
well-versed in every culture and he was
a vegetarian or vegan broke a little
believe me he's vegetarian that's the
very deliberate choice because in the
joint
that's another low broker money people
been asking for that for a long time a
blood and blood out convention bro where
we get in everybody from American me and
everybody from bloody blood
one day and have a meet and greet and
we'll watch all the movies together
back-to-back and kidnap you there to put
you on stage and ask questions you
should be like like blood and blood out
con right oh my god you have no idea
oh so I was at the wrestling match and I
took a picture with this guy's minutes a
junkyard dog right a black wrestler and
then goes oh Jenny could you pretend
you're choking me man and man it was a
joke to me bro but kind of hard he goes
this is for cheap times man hey bro
Jewish did you think that if they were
going to kill him in a movie I thought
some was gonna come up you know cuz
you're trying to read I both saw the
killer over here and then I knew there
was something fishy with that comb to
get everybody's like they started like
you kind of feel some distance you mean
from the leader and stuff because he's
kind of getting soft
I knew someone's gonna get dusty bro
shocked or the angry rotor noise
[ __ ] no man really how I'm surprised
at how usually at about it what's
whatever the actor he don't know
laughter huh do you get to kill you in
the movie steady yeah 60 seconds
yeah he won a special page
here's his gray he's a good time he
passed away two weeks after we finished
so we never got to see it I don't know
he might have seen it got caught maybe
an early cut I doubt it I doubt it
it's too bad he was really great to work
with really great although he was a
little bit you know
yeah uncoordinated with the ice pick and
he actually got me there even though I
was wearing something it's still he
couldn't control it well he nothing it's
slip to the side without the right of
the broker
took truly to do yeah well he you know
he was kind of shaking so they had a one
of the one of the stunt guys
stunk I did it actually did you guys
shoot an actual prison or you shot it
and Ally Condie Jo San Quentin your
inner bad yeah in fact we shot in one of
Danny Trejo's old cells it was very
intense
people were immediate like his graffiti
one day that it tacos what was the work
in prison so no not homes whatever was
going on those guys are gonna take care
of business and they did while we were
there Wow yeah I was pretty intimidating
the first thing that that gets you is
they have you sign a document that that
you agree that you understand that if
you're taking hostage for any situation
that the government will do nothing to
demarcate negotiate for your freedom
yeah you're basically signing away your
life and it Sobers you up but it but
certainly because Jimmy was in the movie
Ginny
Jimmy was an ex-con Danny's an ex-con
and there was another guy in there who's
next con they were going through some
serious PTSD while we were sitting yeah
being in there absolutely let they were
like did that they were actually back in
there in a way well you kind of you know
we actually when we finished filming
there they built an exact replica of the
tiers at Raleigh studios and so we were
shooting in there and while we were
shooting in San Quentin there was a
certain there were routines that we had
to follow every single day they had to
count every screwdriver every wrench
everything that we brought in and it had
to be counted out so everything was
working according to the prison rules
everywhere we walked we had to be
escorted everywhere we went we had to
wear certain clothing to identify us as
actors over a period of time because
certain things happen that we were also
identified as inmates because we were
dressed like everybody else so little by
little we had to change we had to wear
certain things like a lanyard eventually
or a
cut jersey like a football jersey to
identify us well once you get into that
system and you're there for quite a
while and you leave and we're working in
Raleigh studios when I walk we finished
shooting one of the scenes and I was
walking out of my cell and I started
looking for my lanyard just goes to show
you how quick your mind adjust to that
kind of routine I am I actually almost I
started weeping because I felt like an
inmate like I was conditioned to look
for certain things to behave a certain
way and it just made me really sad for
so many of our gente that end up there
many of them for trivial reasons because
of presidents or what have you
the criminal justice system is stacked
against us it made me really upset angry
and hurt that we have to go through that
yeah as a people day in and day out like
African Americans do too you know
there's a guy they came to my comedy
show in Phoenix and his uncle just came
out of prison and the uncle got locked
up when I was a kid he just came up he
sure had a LAPD helicopter in Boyle
Heights because it was because they were
there was chasing him and he just
started shooting at it I don't know if
he shot it down but he shot it and he
did 38 years I'm a heat chest came out I
mean he was locked up when I was a kid
he was locked up when I was a drug
addict he was like that when I tried to
a comedy he was mad pretty much is each
I was like God and I saw a photo of him
I'm like wow old man bro old man with
that was that that's their like he could
look at her he could see a bow away yeah
yeah they're like sharks they're like no
expression I thought all I did there's
one thing one thing I did notice was
those guys are very respectful for one
thing if they bump into you or anything
like that there's always an excuse
you know dispenser mckernon you know
because the bottom line to every
argument is murder
it's a matter of survival and so you've
got no like guards for example they
don't have any weapons is the only thing
that keeps them alive is respect for the
inmates and if they're they get out of
line well what's what's to protect them
so inmates are no different to they
respect each other because the bottom
line to arguing is murder
well do that extra who started off
working with you guys they quit because
they were scared extras
yeah we had no extra dough they were all
inmates they were all the real inmates
Wow Colette America really had extras
bloody quid so you have real enemies
hanging out when we were in the prison
Wow guys around us their own inmates
well behaved right yeah and very
protective of us because again that was
a working prison so they had their
issues so they told us if you guys they
came to us discreetly and said look
stuff is going on and if anything ever
happens you guys just get behind us no
other level with two Broke Billy Bob
Thornton oh yeah Johnny Bob and then
like me little naughty young yeah man a
lot of people huh then the old man
wasn't Mabel I wanted to at the parade I
said I don't want his pork chop I want
his life Lenny Lenny flirty yeah he was
really good you know those guys regarded
because they were real inmates when
we're doing that seen those guys thought
that he really was the guy like that
that he was Big Al and they asked you
know to them it's it's real and so the
question that kept coming up to me was
we are gonna kill him right they were
serious
they were asking really this guy we're
gonna kill him right you know he
provides the lies of the level Ritter
will deal with the chow hall they're
written but you know you can improvise
too good
now you run it right you're at the wrong
train sorry Familia which I along made
the lawyer there right yeah a man from
convict to lawyer we were we right now
we were we were in now we did a show in
Merced No Modesto California and it was
a night that the Raiders lost because of
that well the Chuck you wrote rule oh
yeah everybody that was exciting
yes everybody loved driver everybody
security guard was a goddamn Oakland
Raider fan and and if you're a 49er fan
you're getting cursed out so that's what
they arguing they're not no van at all I
thought they're gonna pull over and
fight oh so you were 49er fan now I
always been a 49 I would have been a
49ers fan [ __ ]
oh so you start starting with my Raiders
[ __ ] lost huh
at least you're honest about who you
like with your shitty-ass team right
there are you doing [ __ ] maybe I want to
hang on afterwards not but just drop us
off in Modesto California and we did at
the Modesto the state theater and Joe
Diaz is watching me famiglia
that's right [ __ ] not parable of
our time he's watching me Familia my
Familia and he watched that movie over
and over he calls it for that part where
he said Morales nice and Morales I'm
Jimmy Smith sons I'll make it yeah going
at a PG Griego cuz you bear to our white
chickie Yeah right the taquitos
yeah that was a funny funny scene a good
thing is that little boy there were two
kids one of one of them was the one that
was that kid yelling and stuff like that
there was another little boy that they
had to do the nude scene
yeah but happiness we were having
trouble with the little boy who was
gonna do the kicking and yes like that
and so he wouldn't come out of it you
know so unless you have kids you don't
know how to
get them to do things right so I want
order to talk to the kid right and I
said hey mijo
how you doing okay that's that's you
know that's a little tough to do I know
he says but listen dude do you like the
Power Rangers he says yeah man is ice
little beasts which one's your favorite
one because my daughter she really likes
the green one he says yeah and I like
this what it says and they do all those
kids and stuff honey I said yeah go out
there and do the Power Rangers every
shot right there in Boyle Heights right
under the bridge and look at that
another bridge yeah yeah my wife is
right neighborhood yeah I know like just
like blood and blood I grew up in Boyle
Heights and like I've been living my
hair my whole life that I know like
basically well I I could start my own
app and let you know what's PETA getting
r5 and what gangs in that neighborhood
yeah exactly man like I know you would
shot say a white fence you know I was
talking to my wife because she grew up
in Boyle Heights we're talking about
when the street says I'm a Chavez used
to be Brooklyn Brooklyn Beckham is to be
Brooklyn but the original name was
Chavez but it oh that yeah the original
name was Chavez it was named after City
Councilman I think back in the early
days of Los Angeles his name was Chavez
that's why I was rid of Java's ravine
it's just it's named after him so we
just started that you started Latino
theater company along with Jose Luis
Valenzuela
yeah and now Molina Mendez Lopez when
you start something that you started for
what to start to a producer role plays
it acting it with your friends and
producer and put them on stage yeah well
so how does that work to to create an
alternative to the stereotype
yeah and also to
but all your rows are positive a gang
banger have the ability to play lead
roles yes so I mean when in a movie was
I going to be able to play Ruben Salazar
you know waiting for that matter or
class journalist we had the other camera
here bro the guy who wrote the book the
revolt of the cocoros people whose
concept that goes to that we had the
director at the head of the retro
documentary where did that play here bro
friend of mine the wrote the script he
had the rights originally and the script
was really good
did you know the guy Oscar I didn't know
no but he he worked with he had this
gentleman had worked with with he'll
Ashby who was huge back in his day won
multiple Oscars for his films and he was
how ask me is creative associate he
taught him how to work computers into
filmmaking and rigged his name is Rick
by the Rick got the rights
met the family and wrote the script for
the movie and it's a terrific script but
there's always been issues between the
family and producers about how to be
portrayed and you know the same thing
with blender blend out in American mean
that those kinds of issues come up and
also because they're Latino projects
yeah the funding is always missing if
you're gonna be able to do it the way
you want to do it you have to do it
outside of the studio's yes them so you
have to find your own money if you do it
through the studio system well then
you're gonna get Brad Pitt to play him
yeah played the wall Tom Cruise like
when they offer Johnny Depp the role of
Pancho Villa you twittered though right
he turned it down he said you want don't
want some honky from Kentucky playing
Marlon Brando played some plates apart
yeah well Robbie Ben Z they walk but
that's been the norm although it's
changing little by little the problem of
course is always the the Hollywood
storytelling formula if you do
la Llorona if you do oscar set Acosta
yeah they're gonna portray them like in
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas it's the
drug thing yeah it's the dark side that
you want to play because they say that's
more exciting
well of course like with Latino projects
what we do that gotta do the cartel
thing we got to do the drug thing you
know rather they do ruin Salazar or
sister Chao is the right way or Oscar
set Acosta or don't notice where the F
for about like a latina or or a black
african-american woman can ever be in a
role where she leaned without something
holding her back in her in the more in a
movie you know like ah but she gotta go
take care of her old grandma oh she got
to take care of her daughter somewhere
your crazy brother
Whoopi Goldberg was pitching the Rosa
Parks story and they they wanted a white
person a player killing me and she said
she's black she was very light-skinned
but you know it's it's like that's the
mentality I think Guillermo del Toro was
doing a Q&A where he was talking about
pitching a story also and he had written
a script and he's meeting with these
execs and they're asking him yeah yeah
they're saying yeah that we'd love the
story well it's also could be in it yeah
yeah yeah
and who's going to direct it well me
he's but you have an accent dwell on
that one you have an accent so you can't
direct the movie that you wrote how the
hell about Gibbs City
[ __ ] your grace Apocalypto bro I don't
know he's got the money are you worried
that's an independent producer yeah he
and Spielberg are probably only two they
could do that yeah but you got to make
at least ten movie would they pay you 30
million they were all successful yeah
anybody even yo ass you know this movie
were super laden with vampires super
loud oh but the movie or though actually
super lotto win win the Mega Million or
what was the one with a great one the
billion dollars
dollars Powerball were so whoever is
active on social media Instagram not
very much if they get you that man we
gotta get you a little pain I had
Instagram and I did and I have facebook
but I don't get in there a lot you know
everybody gets a news from social media
and they think everything's true they do
bro like I saw the arrested piece pretty
Marshall you know and and it was not
pretty Marshall photo boy it was that
comedian or a Brooklynite night night
already you know have her selling you
know kids out of a pizza store to you
poor thing
man and funny man when I when I did them
when I did a movie I did a movie called
I'm not like that no more and in 2009
but it was funny like I'm I was doing
another movie with Paul Rodriguez then
we went the movie went straight to
Netflix a million-to-one know how mr.
Walia was that the party deported hard
warning and the Prem everybody my CD in
the whole movie bro like I'm in friends
everybody party against everybody
everybody a [ __ ] movie the producer
that movie wanted to do a movie the lady
that's the one with Jack Nicholson it's
called the deportation already deported
deported yeah so we was close to tears a
tour of the lead and he get deported
because I think it Mexican yeah and then
be apology to play these like morning
snowing like crazy cowboys and Mexico
that came home she need jobs
I gave already tell me it's kind of like
his pre coyotes right you're setting him
up doing work to raise money yes oh man
I don't know how to acted that movie and
it's within my ankle told somebody I
actually did the music video with Cheech
for born in East oh yeah yeah the music
we shot in Tijuana
it was really cool production company
was cuckoo bananas over the
boy you have a Twitter Facebook yes did
you have a Facebook yes I do he'll shoot
me on Facebook
Ricky Castillo man on Instagram inst
instead I don't even remember that
because I try to look you up on
Instagram I think it's under the title I
think it's I think one of them is the
name of the book that I the novel that I
wrote the dead of summer dead of summer
something underscore like then my wife
has a mole okay so the producer of that
movie he hired of this kind of Kristen
says ma and he paid him some cash and he
turned my CD comedy album which was 70
minutes 60 minutes 30 minutes actually
he converted that into an actual script
based on what everything you heard in
the comment he just used all the ideas
for my company and we made him the guy
actually was serious from we shot the
movie but he did a script and we
actually shot the movie apology appeared
my father we shot in 9 days and we
nowhere but we actually did it and
that's the bottom we at least our sooner
or later we're gonna rebuy in the movie
and redo it ourselves
I think by the rights and combine it
with a special or something yeah
material that's the whole idea is to
keep just keep doing stuff yes you get
better that way and put it out there
there's a lot of windows of exhibition
now you know before it was just the
theatres yeah baby television there were
three networks maybe yeah
well you could watch ruku has an old
channel but it could be a star of Roku
what are you doing right now mr.
Castillo well I did in other words the
romantic comedy that's probably out next
year
there's the pilot that we did for
DeWanna the series that's gonna be at
Sundance or at Slamdance
and then there's the
kind of a sci-fi thing that I did Danny
Trejo's in it also called the the green
ghost that will be out next year also
directed by Michael Olmos
Eddie's it is hard son
if anybody late who are listening or
watching we got people here like hitting
us up a Minnesota bunch of like showing
your soda they want to get ahold of you
this is gonna get hold of you at
Facebook yes yeah but you also have a
publicist right yes Brenda Brenda
Blethyn man was cool man when we saw you
on the parade don't ask me her number
it was you because I saw you in the
arena of the arena agency no no the
Christmas parade
I saw I think I steal first no I saw him
third before him I saw the guy from
Boulevard Knights Richard Richard Angus
in Eagan he gigas and then I saw a guy
that was in cheek window man I bet
they're not a veteran and his car then I
saw this fool Oh what and I were just
[ __ ] poor renderable [ __ ] was badass
bro I never had there been a parade
especially like in East LA my
neighborhood oh you had the yeah the
Mexican Independence yeah no I didn't
even know there was one me neither it
was happening we could go two weeks ago
yeah it's a week ago the first time
somebody mentioned you they said hey you
know if you seen Felipe Esparza and I
and I I automatically thought cuz they
said he's doing comedy and I said he's
doing comedy and and they said yeah he's
doing calm and he's really good you
let's go see him and I said Philippe is
back cuz there was a Philippe Esparza
the death row campesino and he's and
they said cuz you won't hear because
they said you know him you know Phillipe
Esparza and I said yeah I know it's his
son what did you eat
you got younger kale yeah but you guys
shows no I got some in January around
here in West Covina but don't have
details oh good man number 50 Lisa
Partha another casserole no internet
Castro tamales no I will be make it
tamales this weekend and possibly maybe
tempura
oh shut up okay man shout out to Alex
the large he's right there big fan he
bought it he bought a bunch of arm I saw
that fully spent like five hundred
dollars or numb our toothpaste is maxi
pads and all kinda stuff bro and he'll
donate it but also oh yeah our style
yeah December 24 ten o'clock in the
morning 8 o'clock 8 o'clock in the
moment up in the morning we're all gonna
meet up mother Bella park montebello
park or he spent a fortune on the bus
Christmassy yeah and we're gonna go good
morning where there was the original
style lowriders mm-hmm it doesn't have
to be a lowrider but most of these are
these are hundred low riders and they're
all gonna be filled with stuff for the
homeless people and they're cruising
from Montebello Park to Whittier
oh we did it last year we had a big
motorcade we stopped the streets eat
what they no permit for that but
somebody was everybody's help yes or you
what would you call to arica steal and
if you show up mammals make sure we'll
put you a limousine will put your dog a
convertible forever I can see you but
it's not uh it's not a sanctioned parade
we just and you just pass out everybody
brings different things I would just
pass out stuff to the homeless but some
of these cars that was you there was a
car like a um one of those 1940 bakery
trucks and if who had it all primered
out like it looked like hey look in 1930
yes he had all brown like a UPS truck
hmm all fixed up and the inside was
you could put bad inside you remember
those oh yeah I saw one on the 210
freeway it's on a flatbed truck they
were taking it somewhere for an exhibit
or something was beautiful Helms bakery
in Atlanta Georgia old one what's up
fool orbital chair Oh improv Lisa who's
gonna see you there you coming bringing
all the tomatoes and rodrigo's hosting
and then we've got Johnny Roque doing a
spot Chris Estrada Rachel Wolfson and
then you little fools oh and Denver
Colorado we have our Lydia Popovich
hater Tuesday whether you vote or is it
myself
Johnny Johnny - I'll be tight oh yeah
it's gonna be awesome
they sure bet was that I was gonna
actually use your theater company still
going strong I don't I'm not part of the
company anymore but that theater now is
it's still running the latc okay they do
productions all the time thank you so
much for coming in also uh Christmas Eve
December 24 I don't know if I said New
Year's Eve Christmas Eve December 24
Milo belleau Park at 8 o'clock even if
you can't cruise with us if you have
stuff to bring over just bring it over
and we're gonna all be eight down in
skid row and there's no way we're good
that's trees gonna be nothing but
lowriders so you want to stop by man and
just stop by bad is it say hello is that
the same as Montevideo Park yeah okay no
second phone then yeah I'm trying to see
if you have Montebello and Montevideo
how you supposed to say but then we get
all you know you know
I like I like did you mention that [ __ ]
because that [ __ ] works we brought what
I've been Paso Robles and I saw their
lady doing the news and she said Paso
Robles how can you live that's a road I
put my head Bob Rose I was disrespectful
everybody know they were plowed in that
field I was stuck in an airport very
tiny airport in New Mexico one time
going to a film with another actress
right and we were just sitting there for
so long we just we just started talking
she's she's a gotcha
so we were talking about the project we
were doing and you know because a bunch
of us Latinos were in it and we started
talking about language and I said well
you know in this country the English
only thing I said you can't live in this
country and not be multilingual some of
us do it better than others but you
can't just have English here I and she
says what do you mean I said
well for example this is not New
Mexico's New Mexico and if you go to the
East Coast and you go to Vermont that's
French and if you go to Minnesota that's
Native American and if you go to
Colorado that's Spanish so you can go
all around the country and speak
multi-lingual e but then people say that
if you mispronounce it you're doing
something right if you do something
wrong then you're right how does that
make any sense and if you pronounce
something right like that judge in Texas
would know that mother that she was
making her daughter a second-class
citizen for speaking Spanish in other
words to him saying Texas is correct but
saying that house is wrong but the
office they had it was called mecca as
originally exactly belfontaine before
beyond so you know the thing this is
actress I was talking to you know her
you could see her eyes darting back and
forth and the wheels are spinning like
yeah that kind of makes sense you're
right but you know but it's a
conditioning that if you say Santa
Monica where is that I took a crown his
class one time and the guy teaching the
class so give me a holiday I'm all Cinco
de Maya never heard of it
any he said he was raised in Sam
go and then there was a white ship
behind on oh my god you never heard of
Cinco DeMayo she from the castle was so
full a big shout out to a meadow meadow
meadow right here are the fool continued
oh yeah thank you very much that way to
a [ __ ] through that blood and blood
out live or the blood in blood out
convention broom I will make it a play
which version
I don't know right we gotta get up got
the what food to pass sorry what scene
because that's a pork chop bro have you
seen in Spanish oh no bad yeah yeah dude
we could we could we can abide the
original the English versions didn't
have it right so we have to get the
Spanish one with the English subtitles
to have always talked when I tell people
and I'm we had Damon chopper here and
they told her that it was Disney we
couldn't believe it right
and I remember deciding people now now
bro you don't understand why was one was
whatever my American me but the other
one was produced by Disney but they
don't know what the other is talking
about the you're convinced don't know
isn't worried about Joker smiley happy
the dwarves were so cool shout out to
the Latino acting studio right Los
Angeles theater Center yeah man Casa o